dr. Tara Narula joins us at the table to
discuss Tara I think most people hadn't
even heard of this procedure until
yesterday so what is it exactly and how
do you discover it an embolization is a
procedure we've had since the 1970s and
basically the idea is to cut off the
blood supply to a lesion in order to
shrink it or to prevent bleeding and so
what we do is we take a catheter which
is a very tiny small tube almost
spaghetti sized it goes up through an
artery in the groin into the aorta and
then into one of the renal arteries the
artery that supplies blood to the kidney
you then find the smaller artery that's
supplying blood to that particular
lesion and through the catheter you
inject some sort of material or
particles a gel foam or coil that
essentially closes that blood vessel off
so no blood oxygen or nutrients can get
to the lesion it shrinks and essentially
that tissues I only planned in advance
those kind of procedures yes yes it was
interesting there are so few details but
one thing they did say was not benign so
what they're trying to say is not camp
they said it was benign exactly exactly
so not cancerous and there are many
different types of benign lesions we
have no idea which one she had the most
common one would be something called an
angio mile lipoma a collection of blood
vessel tissue as well as muscle cells
and fat cells can be found in women in
the middle age or arteriovenous
malformations or aneurysms
she'll be there for a week we're told is
that normal so typically for
embolization it's an outpatient
procedure you do go home the next day or
even the same day the fact that she's
staying for a week may be that they're
taking extra precautions it could be
that her lesion was particularly complex
or large or there can be complications
rarely something called post
embolization syndrome where you can get
fever nausea vomiting and pain or other
complications like infection bleeding in
the groin contrast problem with the IV
dye they use that affects the kidneys so
there are other complications that can
happen all right
dr. Narula thank you so much